earlier this week Axios got their hands
on a leaked document from a Republican
member of Congress that pretty much laid
out everything that the Republican Party
is essentially covering for Donald Trump
on right now they came out with this
list of things that they're worried
Democrats are going to investigate if
they take back power in the House or
Senate or both here's the list I got to
read this here the Trump family
businesses and whether they comply with
the Constitution's emoluments clause
Trump's dealings with Russia the payment
to stormy Daniels James commis firing
Trump's firing of US attorneys Trump's
proposed transgender ban for the
military Treasury secretary minuchin x'
business dealings White House staffs
personal email use cabinet secretary
travel office expenses and other misused
perks discussion of classified
information at mar-a-lago Kushner's
ethics law compliance dismissal of
members of the epa board of scientific
counselors travel ban family separation
policy hurricane response to puerto rico
election security and hacking White
House security clearances those are just
some of the issues that the GOP laid out
in their super secret we can't lose
document that they think Democrats are
going to start investigating if they
take back over after the midterms but
what it also means is that they know
every single one of these things on this
list I just read to you is a big big
problem for the administration and they
know that there's obviously something
worthwhile in all of those things to
begin investigating personally as much
as I dislike this entire administration
I think the very first thing needs to be
investigated would be the hurricane
response in Puerto Rico
hey we still that Island is still not
put back together you still have people
living under those blue roof FEMA tarps
you still have people without
electricity the government still won't
tell us the official death toll
of Hurricane Maria they don't have
access to clean water we only found out
a week or two ago that they left donated
supplies in a tractor trailer sitting in
a parking lot to rot a baby food baby
formula things that we needed down there
people donated here from the states and
sent down to the island and we just left
it government left it FEMA was in charge
of dispersing it but when they pulled
out of the island or excuse me the
National Guard when they pulled out they
said yeah we'll just leave this thing
here they'll know what to do here's your
here's your stuff come and get it except
nobody even bothered to say that much so
it rotted so yeah I think the response
to Hurricane Maria and Puerto Rico would
be a phenomenal place to start in terms
of investigations people died in that
one okay but these other ones here the
Komi firing yeah okay that's likely
obstruction based on what we know so far
maybe not it's pointing that way but the
bottom line is that Republicans
understand that every single one of
these could be a campaign issue that's
why they were circulating this document
that's why they wanted to raise
awareness amongst members of their party
so that they knew what they were up
against the Democrats are playing it
smart though they're not running on
impeachment they're not running on
investigations that are gonna be
launched the first day no they are to
their credit out there talking about
issues they've learned it appears at
this point from the mistakes of 2014 and
2016 if you want to beat these folks
you've gotta talk about the issues we
have to take another quick break you're
watching the David Pakman show
we'll be right back
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankest one recent one is a Robert
Rice's new book the common good also
bunk by Kevin Young useful in preparing
me for the pseudo-science miniseries
that we're producing and if you are a
david pakman show viewer or listener you
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on youtube use the link in the
video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n